think I think oh yeah we've got this out
for you guys really and I'm not fond of
this outfit hey thanks for the follow so
I'm gonna change her back to the novel
don't say I don't do anything for you
okay so that's it we've got the key
there now we got so many guns and ammo
and all old things
so did we examine this and this is where
we oh this is where we got the key okay
it's a fake it's a fancy-looking key
let's put this got so much stuff like we
don't need all this stuff
you and I you in there for another day
still need folks these keys I think
thank you for following torques and I'm
glad
Zaa middle Summerlin Novick so we have
just progressed but I can't remember
what we were supposed to do well what's
our objective guys
anyone remember oh yeah those weird
taxidermy things Oh power panel parts in
the clock room right in the east storage
room and the clock tower wha the left
one in third floor east storage room
something goes wrong you need more than
one please
I mean don't stop that's top thank you
for following okay so East storage room
third floor and the clock tower
what Florian now is that is that the
clock tower that's the same place right
whenever I spots face looking I forget
how like nerve-racking everything is
absolutely everything you know I'm gonna
end up turning around and SEC just to
put my loop back my phone every time
[Music]
just go through you will follow me he's
stupid you don't know how shy my
inventories fall I won't I won the maze
you know what he might actually I want
this too
[ __ ] I also need to get that which
frickin door who is that
what is that I don't know Brady what's
happening
just exploring all the things right
anyway here we go just put a bunch of
stuff away what probably do we not need
we got 515 9-millimeter okay so we don't
have any more ammo for you so we'll put
you away we'll put you away
sure Oh like that's the 9-millimeter
bullets
in that case give away and give away
Shir Hever plank plank I was watching at
the last couple of weeks okay we can
come back to get more stuff or just oh I
saw the Thomas the Tank Engine more as
well
I love hilarious can you imagine whoa
hey hey mr. Sam beam let me just turn
around
I'm not even here mr. zombie stealth
mode
okay great and he was the one that was
in yeah so we evaded it like a mouse
Resident Evil seven mannequins hey I see
wait I wanna I don't want to waste the
bullet on you I will
I evade it hi thanks for bringing my
attention too hard and that's not so now
I'm just going around in circles
great oh okay we got cog one why are we
getting cokes what are the Cubs for
that's a very good question I don't
really know what are they for there's a
blue hair up on the balcony
about two halves to boomers size there's
the safe room down here anyway it's
about go down yeah
even I'm trying to learn it
trying not to save as much
[Music]
Oh does this mean that we're going to
encounter mr. X in the exact same
but he's already we've already seen him
[Music]
are you
what
so barricaded oh [ __ ] yeah my exactly
I'm annoyed you bastard
don't get that Cup I won't you get into
safe room so annoying you think you know
a map you think you know yeah right
mantas two shots
that's all it took I'm very surprised at
that the game is going easy on me Wow
look at these herbs - really is
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
yeah I just read some some and they're
telling me that it wasn't least we can
go up here now
[ __ ] you mr. X I don't think you can go
this way Johnny I don't know
do you just close the door again
he's like Nick it's raining my hat will
get wrecked
where's the clock button
I even needs to go in through that way
you can dance if you want to if you
don't dance do I need to go you I
already think so oh hi you're there
right okay well I'm gonna go back up hi
oh my god okay
[Music]
I don't think so okay what am i doing
now
why can I not seem to locate this
cloakroom what the hell is wrong with me
I'll plug tower there right
okay so I can't get from that way anyway
hmm what happens if I come up here and
go downstairs
oh I haven't really been in to do this
so I'll check that out this douche bag
is gone
[Music]
[Music]
hey Slugger boys thanks so much for the
poverty through super chart week let me
read what it says one sec you said hey
are you already the paver hey hey and
thank you
hopefully not yep
Hey
look to explore that whole of that area
don't really fancy that if you wonder
why I'm walking it's because I tracked
him mr. X I mean thanks so much what was
this weight was like I always have to
pick how are you I'm good thank you I've
had I've had a pretty good day at work I
did some some good things I did a bit of
vector math which I am oddly proud of
how many times we're playing this game I
don't enjoy this but also how many times
have I said I do enjoy this I think why
not also how are you I didn't ask how
you were that's very rude if someone
asks how you are you should probably
follow them up and then ask them how
they are that's just social ethic oh
yeah so someone left isn't it third
floor yeah
[Music]
Oh
at least they can't go up ladders you
have to do this bloody thing again I
don't have it oh that sucks don't have
it
so basically you need to text fix this
so what do I do now how's your new job
it's good things it's very good I'm
actually really like you money job it's
it's pretty tiring like I'm not gonna
lie
[Music]
we don't even know what I needed that
hug forward to be honest that's weed
this again police chief's office give me
some power panel parts to fix the issue
sent a few spare parts with him and he
reported that he left one in the third
floor east storage how many do I need do
I just need one maybe I need one police
chief's office is that the save room
that I was in earlier chief's office
oh that locked on okay then the book is
still down here on the side I think the
book might be in my storage box
so much to me not running my so loud
than I thought
I'm pretty sure is behind me my god yeah
he's down there right now
okay stop running girl but also there's
zombies thank you thank you blanket
blanket do the plank
[Music]
let me out you still need that key oh
that's okay wait one sec yes let's do
this
no that would be too easy
No
yeah
thank you for subscribing
oh I will go back but I don't worry but
that was not fun that was so scary
I gave me a headache
I'm sure you've got headache too yes
he's like me all right how many do we
need
oh I need to so he needs to get to the
clock tower okay hmm thank God a key
card
thank God yeah you know quite that I am
what a combo look around mixed mr. axe I
know how unlucky why we still need one
more electric heart
[Music]
walking around there just does not care
he's blocking up my path and my future
his own selfish gains square is to
reload right and I'm not being stupid
go x2 Rina yes question
in here can't reload it
no I met I mean a handgun Bondi's mind
within me now
Oh submachine gun boys Wow
guns like her back
hmm
we've got enough perps Oh proud of us
this let's go
oh here's the Redbook I knew I had it
there's something inside what am I look
at it then maybe I did
oh I see
forget that chill out so I okay so I
gotta get the job read book we can do
that if I know how to do that yeah
I'm always running around with so much
stuff I don't know what keys are need
oh he's an angry boy how dare you
disrespect his Fedora greatness I'm
sorry please don't hate me mr. X I've
been too late for that he hates
everything I don't know maybe not
everything making sure X is like his
special someone you know
[Music]
happening around me but I've saved so
that's something
[Music]
just ship me working mouth don't care I
suspicious Oh came back for sure she
liquor won't hurt you if you don't hurt
me now that I have so kindly been gifted
this
just going straight to the man with the
hand we are going to the man it's gonna
be right yes yes it's a bit maze-like
I get confused easily I'm sorry mr. X is
down here so I'm just gonna casually
walk and hope that we don't bump into
him that was weird did you hear that it
sounds like a bird or baby we made it
yes by now that one now we may put em on
I can't remember if we even use this or
early on maybe it was literally just for
her but I mean don't run don't freak out
everything will be okay
okay I'm tired I compose myself
are you proud of me you pardon me Hey as
this Sara dare Roquefort don't get good
how are you
how the hell's your day going great no
you finally find I was in blocks
just trying to remember why this is used
oh the computer do I need to get in
there what do you get from the computer
again I forget
me I'm just gonna go do things I hope
that I get some good stuff
little one just another one just a
little one opening mr. excellent yeah
just oh I hear footsteps is he coming
from where I'm going in cuz that would
be very unfortunate and it seems to be
the case
I went the wrong way this is not where I
was supposed to go and now there's
liquors on a mystery and my life is a
terrible thing oh I have a roll of film
too right
DCAM what was that for again - sure okay
maybe yeah so I went up completely the
wrong way I thought that door led to the
whole way but that was the other door so
I'm an idiot I want them away I know
right so I need to be on second floor go
through the shower
I remember now right
yeah I don't why I know the budges USB I
remember just I'm just trying to figure
out where go in okay
please don't say mister except don't
like how much mr. X is in this I'm just
really not enjoying how much is in this
you would be [ __ ] music me get out
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm we finally got this submachine gun
right I'm not a blood that mean and
liquor is about yes finally get ready
oh this means I think we got all of them
now
okay we got everything there was to get
where'd you know where'd you know we
could go down to that other place and
use those keys and get old stuff we
could go down to basement and then use
the badge I just can't remember actually
it probably wouldn't be the same anyway
where we find there like
the thing to move the thing and the
library thing the bookcases thing in
this room this room yeah I'm not sure
[Music]
huh like hanging out and mr. X is just
totally coming to watch me I'm gonna go
down the ladder set okay
I'm just passing through okay Oh bowls I
need to get the other one yeah cuz I
have like no room for anything anyways
I can guess a I can get one thing one or
two maybe
[Music]
my tests your shots are how compose I am
I think I've been playing this game
maybe for [ __ ] long but the jump says
is still getting me but yeah I'm kind of
like famous last words
we shall find out - 3 - 2 H wait it's
not more storage space if so then I will
be a happy duckling 208 oh no it's not I
mean yeah sure I feel I feel almost like
all the reviews like you get enough ammo
I feel like so much - ok so I'm out of
things down
[Music]
only bangs with no mr. X is fine I think
he was that now
[Music]
[Music]
so I should put one of these away
so you've got so much ammo for this guy
we should probably use it don't we got
miss perhaps they're perfect you can
find another red herb that great it's
alright if not I've got more green herbs
[Music]
party I don't waste my ammo as as badly
as other people it's cuz I'm whipped
right so I just I would prefer to run
away if I can Blanken
actually no sure because I should get
more pouches hid in my head off thanks
for subscribing
I just um be he's just in the freaking
way
hey accommodation of zombies and it is
it's not good one my disgruntled he's
still good
does he not go back for his heart he
really doesn't have a song doesn't even
care about the half that he's wearing I
think you just punched the wall
[Music]
[Music]
should take one of our green hats was it
one of our green
I think mr. X trampled on him and just
stopped him moving completely because he
was twitching before cuz you want to
sneak past some bees when will I ever
get to these frickin room
turn around
[Music]
you are practically guarding stop
campaign but mr. X comes you need go
into it's not cool it's not fun
you just need to get here
that is all I need to do I just mean
together I'm not stuck I just I'm
waiting for mr. X to stop freakin
camping broom not going to he just won't
he just keeps walking up and down here
- OH - oh yeah that's gonna be nice yep
remember guys all - OH - two or three -
tree
ah that's much appreciated okay so now
we have a little bit more so we have
more room which is nice but we still
don't have the little crank for the
library what else we have we have the
badge we have the large gear which means
use on the roof says we've got the USB
dongle key um I know where we need to go
for that yeah screw it I'll just go down
there and see close it get it ready
and there are still some doors that to
be fair that I haven't opened so maybe
yeah
maybe I could go in here the records
room
okay
straight ahead but what's the family
just ahead
[Music]
well that's just bloody fantastic
alright always that it's okay
cat
why
Wow erotic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
can I see it Italian please
quarter past hmm okay
wait no I have to do all that again
thanks for the fall hours
wait okay so this is been when I came
back to get the other key okay okay
start again wait it's actually half
seven I thought no half a otherwise half
seven
[Music]
oh cool you're an hour head that's
that's good and that works up to me cuz
I'm gonna leave it about eight guys just
so you know oh my gosh where is the
other one what is this what the hell I
can't you remember where I found the
other one where do I find the other one
18:54 does
that's a freaking annoying okay remember
when I found the other thing
[Music]
[Music]
dude I even have the machine gun
okay
go get it
yeah of course cost J drain the linen
room of course
the linen room
I am smarter I just don't want to
attract miss X no matter what I keep
thinking as a liquor in here I don't
think there is for her but I'm just
gonna keep walking anyway cuz I really
don't want that to be
see this go at me like Renee look at you
my blood I'm just confused about why I
haven't seen one
it's like it was there when Chris was
around and now all of a sudden it's gone
a skin
Oh what
that one
usually pretty good news I'm getting
impatient I think
yeah that's the last one right that one
first night this will first note this
one first this one
yo Jesus okay
definitely getting impatient now five
this might not be the best way to go I
think I'm gonna go
Oh
I'm okay
oh good for now okay now we can be
reckless
by mr. X I'll see you on the flipside
okay not that way Lisa killed this
letter yes
[Music]
now we can get this one two or three
[Music]
tell me what I own was like pretend wait
nope he was an event
oh yeah and smart you buddy
nice we have believer we have progressed
I love how everyone's so excited for
nemesis it's gonna be good
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's quickly just go to the
library and try and put this in hey
friends you were stalking me and I came
out at just the right time
this way
I can go either way I think the best way
oh yeah Bulls freaking gear if only it
wasn't for lag and shadow rocker could
have told me earlier
and scanners okay I think mr. X did that
for me actually great I know there's no
safe I mean
any dramas I don't like the dramas no
unreal life sometimes the video game so
video game drama this can be fun YouTube
drama is funny to watch but no one
people get that which makes it extremely
boring for you guys on it right
[Music]
[Music]
the other stairs
this one's occupied yes
I wish I could like throw some things
like distracting oh that's fine that
works anyways goodbye bye bye
look he's fun over me he went out there
said give it up
bigboy needed to go back there this is
just a locked door hey Brina mister
remember this kind of baffled me last
time as well I think
didn't fit I tried
[Music]
there it is is what I need
Oh
downstairs don't run because mr. X is
nearby
one side
[Music]
yes I'm still walking cause I'm
terrified the misters gonna hear me
don't judge you don't understand
oh maybe you do his way of watching
that's first person that works I wanted
to come here
what is he coming why isn't he coming
please I'm waiting for mr. axe
[Music]
here he comes how the howl of the un--
states
Oh
okay guys
ah whatever yeah are we gonna go back to
the other room right okay okay make if
we can make it and then we'll just open
up that door and I think I will go and
make dinner don't wanna go to bed too
late it's it's a work night
look at those pixels up there pixels on
the doorframe
[Music]
okay wait for mr. X to go wander off
somewhere else oh I did say shiza I
don't know why I started singing when I
was like in secondary school when I just
kind of comes out every now and then I
think it was like me trying to be all
smart so be like I'm not even in
swearing in school and stuff you know
like teachers nobody ever actually said
that to the teachers Oh probably not
I don't know don't said it cuz I also
learnt
tettemer it which I really hope means
what I think it does but some French
people told me about it my name is
[ __ ] tettemer
I noticed Raisa is a swear word in
German but obviously I went to an
English school so I was like I'm not
really swearing though my baby's lay in
the word and hopefully I might help with
the YouTube probably not huh probably
not
okay great we did it guys but we
progressed so far we've only been on
here for like two hours I'm proud of us
oh yeah this this took me ages the first
time I remember I was social
these little particles of dust are
actually making me think I have dust in
my room coming around my screen so
that's probably a good thing
[Music]
[Music]
okay I did it I'm not too sure how I
know they have YouTube in Germany I'm
just meaning the YouTube might like not
see some words of swearing like more
than others in other languages maybe no
one understands how the algorithm works
so we are just guessing
good to see you again Claire
we've got unfinished business see up in
the neighborhood you'll find it sure you
all right for now I salute you bastard
if you heard her
I just looked for the camera be like
stupid kid if you just hadn't dropped
that [ __ ] thing I could let you go
what she dropped what is she drunk did I
miss the whole worry sherry
it'll be all over soon there has to be a
way out of here I guess it'll go down
now look you what can I use the stuff
throw it I guess to like make it look
like I'm still sleeping let's put it
under the covers and then put my little
shoes on it as well yeah
what I guess that's not right yet
but I'm still gonna
she cold she's like thank you for
subscribing oh there's something in it
that's pretty cool all right
Square with a stand secret scissors I
got my secret scissors
thank you for subscribing how does it he
not know this was here is this
I'm not sure a medical
something-or-other keep pictures though
friend I think she's happy that I
acknowledged her pictures okay welcome
okay so that was my room
Cribbs
there's a cribs
cute paintings generally the fourth
Wednesday's are perfectly great days
because we get snacks and ice cream I
hate the last place I was at the
teachers were all meanings
it was just slowly study study and there
wasn't no ice cream that's a double
negative I love love love it here
Daria 10th there was an important rule
made today everyone must buy a diary get
health check-ups and we ain't allowed
outside by ourselves it's good we don't
have to go school I don't want to go get
pic down right on for my old clothes
especially not by the guy that used to
wear them oh so we're in hand-me-down
guy clothes
Joey 16 the orphanage director is coming
insane so imma gonna wear my most
favoritest checkered blue outfit the
director is tall the director has a
mustache the director is policeman Oh
cutie look this is her favorite outfit
oh well she has one of those wristbands
so she can gain places
hop scotch away this is very well
designed I love it
they've thought about all the tiny
things don't run okay I won't I'll take
that and I haven't been running yeah
she's a little lass
oh now we're in the program
are we gonna see zombie babies cuz that
would be horrific
I don't think so and I think they win
though that far
[Music]
but there's a door over there too I want
to see what's in both places I mean it's
it's probably just logs
that must be that we're out of here
mm-hmm that was too easy
also she be wary of what's outside as
well take the alligator he might be able
to give you some protection
well the dinosaur the t-rex
I'm guessing is it's gonna be locked
anyways right
so I'm probably a skater here yeah
that's so check stop guessing the game
and just going with it fine yes
darn it I need the key don't worry
look oh there's something here I'm sorry
it's been two months since I sent that
letter to Oliver and then all I've
gotten back is nada zip then again
they're all like that once they get
adopted but he's living like a king and
some fancy box home and forgotten all
about us what he thought it was
different then he'd be my friend for
life guess I'm just a fool and set all
the kids down and told them a story
today she said all the kids that get
adopted a turn into food for the
boogeyman that's why no one hears from
them ever again not sure where she gets
her ideas from but she sure got the mind
for writing trashy horror novels there's
something weird going on around here
it's not just cutter Bands stories don't
get me wrong I've been in worse places
and the place is funded by some big drug
company how does the little kid know
this but why can't we call people or go
outside why are there so many doctors
around what's with those shots every day
it's almost like where I'm getting
adopted me
most people go for younger kids so I
figured I was too old but I can't say
I'm not a little happy Who am I kidding
I'm totally psyched I say goodbye to
this place on my 20th okay so he's
definitely not a little boy I'm gonna
try to be my my best to be a good son
someone my new mom and pop can be proud
of Oliver came back in the middle of the
night all messed up screaming help me
and stuff I don't even recognize him at
first
his face was appealing and melted off
he's with the teachers and doctors now
it's just a skin thing they say he'll
get better soon and then we can go on
adventures again zombie kid zombie kids
[Music]
sneaky sneaky
[Music]
how's he doing the mad scientist for
that I guess
[Music]
where am I supposed to go
[Music]
I'm getting a key I'm not going anywhere
we're with the kyboot why we're key here
in the key rock of course
where you going sherry somehow I told
you to stay put
you need to learn to listen me alone
just please talk to teach some manners
to face was created
you are gonna be so [ __ ] sorry
[Music]
I don't think I asked you
the version of mr. X it's all over now
doors locked
where are you show yourself
I know you're in here the longer it
takes me to find you the worse it's
gonna be
keys up give up mister what why couldn't
I get the keys up your butt I thought
that was the way do you know the way
cable sure I know I was supposed to get
the keys off his back
oh my god hi
how much mr. okay whatever it's all over
now
doors locked so I just hide like behind
show yourself
I know you're in here the longer it
takes me to find you the worse it's
gonna be
yeah that was one who is the right of
him they just gotta be here somewhere
maybe I don't know
yes no maybe I don't know I'm your peach
question please
this is your last [ __ ] chance cable
no I was trying to get past it
it would have been okay
okay did she just have to hide this may
we have this it's all over now
doors locked my things I'd like to stay
here mmm
where are you show yourself I know
you're in here the longer it takes me to
find you the worse it's gonna be
we just gotta be here somewhere
which way is it gonna go
no your turns not your time table ah
Jesus maybe I should go over there then
but then I if I don't over there oh you
want a missus I'm not a me anything if I
got over there
oh maybe tonight it's all over now
doors locked
show yourself I know you're in here the
longer it takes me to find you the worse
it's gonna be
hmm we just gotta be here somewhere I
can there's no grabbing his cheese guys
I see you cable
[Music]
I'm just worried cuz I go over there I
live she know what else I go
it's all over now
doors where are you show yourself
I know you're in here the longer it
takes me to find you the worse it's
gonna be
kanna's shut your face
[Music]
this is your last [ __ ] chance show
yourself
[Music]
oh oh that's perfect so best way was to
ditch you go around the whole route I
can't believe I knew each other on the
first girl
good man taken
[ __ ] is my G
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thirty minutes early yeah good to see
you again Claire we've got unfinished
business
what are you talking about don't waste
my [ __ ] time
bring me a pendant or sherry dies
pendant what do you need it for
do you want the girl to die fine where
are you
the orphanage the orphanage where's that
in the neighborhood you'll find it sure
you all right for now I swear you
bastard if you hurt her
sherry is more than all right you aren't
see - I need to worry about that serious
dammit wait [ __ ] it's heroes hide and
seek
okay now I'm gonna say go so thank you
very much for watching I hope you
enjoyed I will we upload this soon and
I'll probably look trim it I usually
just like to trim it down a little bit
but yeah have a lovely day or evening
it's